as one of the most ambitious crossover
events in history Avengers infinity war
featured a miles long cast roster that
brought together all of the corners of
the sprawling Marvel Cinematic Universe
Black Widow Black Panther Iron Man the
guardians of the galaxy the whole
crime-fighting crew was there well
except for Hawkeye ant-man in for most
of the movie The Hulk in the first few
minutes of infinity war
Thanos defeats the Hulk during a fight
on the refugee ship that fled from
Asgard at the end of Thor Ragnarok the
not so Jolly Green Giant didn't appear
in the film again after that and we
finally know why according to the
commentary track from the digital
release of Avengers infinity war the
Hulk wasn't m.i.a because he was ashamed
that Thanos pummeled him to the ground
it's actually even more twisted than
that the Hulk is getting sick of coming
to banners aid every time he and the
Avengers need assistance in the form of
brute force I have an army we have a
Hulk Joe Russo explained people
speculated whether there was some fear
on the Hulk's part about having to face
Santos again but I ultimately think that
he's tired of playing hero to Bruce
Banner it's easy to see why viewers
would rally behind the idea that the
Hulk was in some way emotionally bruised
after his scuffle with Thanos the Hulk
staying and hiding because he was
feeling here that's not exactly a common
occurrence when it comes to our
temperamental green-skinned buddy his
whole shtick is getting angry and
jumping into a fight after all oh stop
just for once in your life don't slice
fear is the opposite of what The Hulk is
about so it's only natural to latch onto
something so rare The Hulk experiencing
an emotion he's rarely felt before and
not fully understanding how to process
it is a solid theory that makes for a
satisfying character arc but the real
reason for the Hulk's absence is way
more fulfilling for two reasons it gives
banners alter-ego the autonomy to become
more than just the muscular
manifestation of banners dark inner
disquiet and it pushes banner to stop
relying on the Hulk to save him from
sticky situations while many Marvel fans
believed Banner to be constantly trying
to hold the Hulk in it looks like the
tables are beginning to turn as the Hulk
finally puts his huge green foot down
Russo elaborated on that dynamic even
more there's a host body that is being
fought over by two distinct
personalities who hate each other we
thought an interesting direction to take
him in is well what if banner who
typically uses the Hulk to solve crisis
situations what if the Hulk were no
longer interested in solving those
problems for banner so the relationship
is becoming increasingly dysfunctional
Russo's explanation here shoots down all
other possible reasons as to why banner
couldn't turn into the Hulk in infinity
war including the suggestion that he was
too angry to transform or that he blamed
himself for what happened on the
Asgardian ship but it also stamps out
one of the more thought-provoking
theories surrounding the character
another unusual fan Theory suggested
that the Hulk was missing from infinity
war because Loki was actually
masquerading as banner that would
certainly explain why there weren't any
Hulk out moments but given that Russo
goes on to focus specifically on banner
and the Hulk's tense relationship that
theory effectively falls apart as well
after the jaw-dropping ending of
Avengers infinity war we've been
operating under the impression that
Avengers 4 will rip out more hearts and
feature more intensity than previously
thought possible and now it looks like
Bruce Banner and the Hulk's turbulent
dynamic will be a major part of that
chaos